folks we got a hot episode of taste buds
coming up right now we get into
charcuterie board versus bread and
butter i will be coming to sand wait
wait wait wait
we also talk about we just played the
beacon theater this week oh you and i we
tell the whole story about that you got
robbed we tell that story you kind of
tell the people what they're in store
for sorry i forgot i'm new to this
let me i will tell you this if you're
looking for the heat if you're looking
for the heat this episode brings the
heat look at this do you have it can you
pick that up are you picking that up
look at this savage
okay he takes a sip of water it spills
all over a wood coffee table he lifts
his foot up that is in a sock and he
runs his sock across the table to wipe
up the water is the bottom of his foot
on the table where i eat
you eat on this table well i mean i eat
on every table
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't put that nice
cloth on it now you you
what
that's currently on your foot and you
run it across the table you saw me do it
i don't know why you have questions
you're not even in your own home
we're not in your home either
you you are kidding me right now what do
you how do you clean your house you walk
around the house with a sock in windows
what are you doing
are you just daniel sunning all your
mirrors and everything what are you
doing
folks i'll be in san francisco in july
go to jonarosinfo.com for tickets more
dates are coming very soon for the
months following july also come to joey
rose's we're open tuesday through sunday
full bar in sandwich shop go to
joeyrosesnyc.com for details guys all
right
i got minneapolis and milwaukee coming
up i got uh
okay let's start this over
syracuse and rochester minneapolis and
milwaukee and i got uh hampton beach and
i got foxwoods those are all in june and
then on sale right now just as of three
days ago
vegas phoenix boulder colorado seattle
portland and vancouver they've been on
sale for three days you can still get
amazing tickets right now savile
countercomedy.com tastebuds they coming
to the mic talking about the food they
hate talking about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste
welcome to t a s
the [ __ ] is bad
hello everybody what's up babe covid
is that what happened i had cobra then i
was on the road and you had covid and
then because you had covet it shifted us
yeah for when we could record
and then when we were able to record you
couldn't record i was uh
because at that point you were making up
work or on the road or something it's a
it's a it's a little tricky that cover
yeah yeah so it's great to have you back
it's nice to be back everybody
uh
we've we you and i have had some fun
things
yes
happened
yes so this is coming out uh this week
this monday the 23rd this episode will
come out just a few days before that
uh and uh we just came off the beacon
theater together yeah you you you
headlined the beacon theater you
headlined the hometown it was sold out
your whole family was there a lot of
friends were there yes and i was very
honored to be on that show
uh opening for you it was a wonderful
experience it was great i mean i plugged
it enough but thank you new york city we
sold out uh
it was just a just a
a really really memorable night i i i it
was beautiful yeah yeah i mean i just
had a blast it was
the crowd was hyped
tons of friends and family there it was
just like you know home hometown show
home field it was beautiful it was
beautiful and thank you by the way
uh
fans
sal fans taste buds fans
uh for coming down to joey roses yes i
went down to joey roses after the show
it was packed
uh and it was everything we did come
down from the show yeah it was awesome
and then on sunday people were coming
through that's awesome it was really
really what a heartwarming experience i
was telling christy d about it i was
like dude
the cheers that sal got the cheers that
i got the cheers the pimp got
the um q stuck his head out the cheers
the queue got sticking his head out the
cheers that chris got when i did when i
told the story about chris headline the
beacon yeah like
it i go dude it just felt so much like
it felt like we were like a community
and it's a it was great it was great and
we didn't tell anyone you were gonna be
on the show oh yeah we purposely kept
that back because you know we wanted to
have a little surprise to everybody yeah
that was fun that was fun yeah and you
got a nice you got a nice pop babe i
never got a pop like that in my life
really yeah that was the biggest pop oh
amazing
people cheered for the sandwich shop
it was loud it got loud
like you were like joey roses and then
well chris
who's the greatest was was was went on
before me and chris uh said by the way
is it john stun yeah it is right
okay
he said uh he goes your next comedian
has the hottest sandwich up in new york
city and everybody started cheering and
i was like
this is so crazy
but watching you walk out and get the
reception you got seeing pimp get the
reception he got it was just it was just
awesome man it was really i was touched
i was floating for a while yeah me too
guys i mean it was just like we do a lot
of shows you know we're on the road all
the time uh and uh you know sometimes
they're just extra extra special that
one
was crazy my grandma was there she's
like 90.
i'm with her for a little while my niece
yeah you did right yeah she was cool
yeah my niece she had so many sandwiches
she did
yes they enjoyed them very much my mom
actually smuggled a bunch out i know i
was with your mom
walking out
uh
that sounds like it's like gonna be a
mom joke
[Laughter]
it wasn't i was with your mom we walked
out together just coincidentally and she
was like talking to me about how she was
smuggling sandwiches it was very funny
yeah she said to me can you get me some
sandwiches i'm like just go get a plate
put a punch in them cover them with
another plate walk out
not stealing them i bought them
yeah thank you for buying sandwiches
yeah of course yeah um
but uh yeah i mean and my even my like
nieces and nephews might
as little as my two and a half and three
and a half year old niece and nephew
were there so like it was just one of
those things you know everybody was side
stage was everybody and it just was like
that night for us at least you know when
we're at a landmark like that with all
of our friends it's just special end you
just feel the buzz by the way cue
talk about field buzz
in rare form i got it on video on
instagram i helped you i caught a little
little bit of it i shot it he helped me
pee help me plug my austin dates i saw
that
what did where did he what happened
where was he coming from
nobody knows i heard i heard he was nice
and lit up but he he was letting
everyone know he was lit up is that he
was very vocal about how drunk he was he
was fun yeah he was very fun he was very
vocal about what he drank which was i
believe he said six margaritas and two
shots that sounds like when you're in
college yeah you're like bro how many
shots i did i drank five beers and seven
shots but i don't know where he was or
who he was with he just kept saying an
old friend i don't know i don't know
where he was i think was what he was
referring to tequila as an old friend
joe do you remember being sidestage you
were having a moment looking at all the
people who performed there and then he
walked in and said they're all pricks
yeah yeah yeah right yeah i was i was
when chris was on stage i was pacing
around because i was a little nervous
and he came up and chastised me at
length
for being nervous
dad started saying things like
you want some you want some advice
i i've played the garden baby i started
doing that uh and then uh and then
started pointing to the pictures of
everybody backstage saying that guy's a
prick that guy's a prick that guy's a
freak it actually is crazy the wall
update and i realized it's pictures of
everybody in the elevator i saw in the
elevator which was the coolest i forgot
to do the elevator thing the the one guy
asked me i forgot to do it you're insane
dude i didn't know it was that's what it
was every one of those photos on the
wall those portraits are of the band or
the person in the elevator
and uh i see i signed it and took my
elevator shot he asked me because i was
about to go on and he goes you want to
do it after and i go yeah yeah let me
just go on first and then i didn't even
know what the significance of it was he
was he just said you want to take a
picture on the wall you know i didn't
know
yeah man i'm always a daylight in a
dollar shop
i swear to god man yeah well it was it
was a great show the crowd was crazy
crazy crazy crowd
and uh yeah
i'll never forget it we'll see hopefully
maybe one day we're there again
uh amazing yeah yeah yeah and then we
hung out they were nice enough to give
us a little reception downstairs
because we had the sandwiches we had a
little open bar everybody went
downstairs yeah played some tunes hung
out got to catch up with people i
haven't seen in a long time yeah so it
was like just one of those just one of
those nights no that was that was a nice
night for you man i'd love to see you
guys play at the uh staten island fairy
hawks stadium
oh yeah
what's that i i might actually be sick
um shout out you know i gotta give a
little shout out to gary perrone
gary is a friend of mine and a friend of
the our show and the guys he was with
the brooklyn cyclones organization
for a long time and they gave us an
impractical joker's day and we had the
bobble heads given out and it was
everything was thinking is that where
those bottle heads came from yeah
probably yeah like well you have several
but yeah the one that says in practical
job
yeah it was great they had us on the
outfield wall they were playing clips
everything they did trivia he's great
anyway we have a long-standing
relationship with him he has now moved
over uh the the standalone yankee
stadium here has transitioned they have
left and we now have the staten island
zone the fairy hawks and he is heading
up that that uh that organization so i
i've been meaning to reach out to me i
wanted me to tweet it for him but this
is even better i just want to give a
shout out goes down and see a staten
island fairy hawks game it's at the
ferry it is a beautiful stadium you had
the
in the background with the city and
stuff and fairy hawks is a pretty also a
really cool name i'm excited to get some
merch that is a cool name yeah it's fun
man i had a few beers there the other
night they should have joey roses stand
there
oh dude that'd be pretty cool dude
that's actually that's actually really
cool yeah you can maybe a pop-up or
someone just try a like i could connect
you okay and they could sell joey rose's
sandwiches at the stadium that'd be
amazing yeah that'd be great let me let
me try to connect you guys okay yeah
yeah yeah um did the game start yet then
over there yeah i went to a game it was
fun no shh i got hammered and it just
it's sick it's sick
the uh well you guys were there for
christmas yeah we were there with like
new york nico and the side talk kids i
saw
yeah pete davidson and kim were supposed
to pull up they canceled like a half
hour before it was it was nuts dude it's
fine pull up is it opening day or
something it was yeah yeah ah yeah nico
and koosh someone said to me oh let's
let's connect and have him come to the
beacon and i think it just fell by the
wayside i don't know that
is so cool yeah yeah he's a young
kid yeah he's a state-owned kid
he lives here oh okay
he's the kid that eats the yeah nick
stuff and says brush your hand
yeah cooch came by joey roses
and review joey rose's which was awesome
shout outs koosh
uh is he a young kid
i can't tell if he's you know i'll meet
him and talk to him i can't tell he's
like 25 or 55.
he has a way about it he looks young but
he doesn't look young i like his swag
he's got swag but he came by and when he
was bi i was talking to him
and uh sabino and uh and i said uh i
said you guys should come on taste buds
oh hell yeah oh that that's actually
he he would fit perfect right because
anybody that's food related like we were
just talking about like uh but tim
dillon may be coming on because he has
such opinions on food and but i want to
have sabino and cujon together so we can
go uh sabino i'm not sure who that is
sabino is his manager but sabine also
has a sandwich shop in brooklyn and he's
also part of there's a whole crew of
really what's this what's his podcast
called again uh the italian uh jeez let
me look it up italian
it's a podcast about it's like a foodie
pocket oh oh it's dope but it's good
michelle we should do that we should do
that yeah unless we'll we can have chas
palmeteri on wherever you want let's
touch growing up italians they're
growing up growing up
it's a pod it's a pod yeah so check that
out growing up italian that's yeah it's
recorded in a deli in brooklyn oh that's
fun that's a lot of fun and follow meals
by cooch on instagram and yeah we should
do an episode with them at joey roses
that would be pretty now new york nico
is just new york guy he's not food no
new york niko i've never met but he's
some yeah he it's a lot of stuff he's a
legend they just that's like their rat
pack
yeah but i want to meet nico man i i i
hear you might have
yeah he's awesome he's such a good guy
nice good shout out to you guys
shout out boys uh shout out to
mozzarella mo
little moe monster is that a real guy
yeah there's a whole crew who's that
it's a whole there's a whole circuit of
these guys
missing out the funniest name
oh what a great name yo we should go
though we should go we should go a
little take a little field trip to a
fairy hawks game i'm down i mean i would
let's do the first pitch no pressure
first pitch
yeah i've always been nervous i had to
throw first we had to throw a first
pitch on the show and she may chris do
it has derose ever throwing a first
pitch that's what i need to say i can't
i can't do it i've been asked i'll stand
there i'll stand there i feel like i i
can throw a ball like i could throw a
ball but i feel like under that
circumstance i'm gonna like pull a
yeah i'll pull a baba bowie so
one more nicety before we get into
things here today
uh i was wearing my god bless shirt oh
yeah
brand new merch by the way in my
neighborhood the other day yeah
um it was just it was a weekend
afternoon oh the other the old shirt
yeah yeah yeah the and it says god bless
on the back it's a black tee it says god
bless on the back of it um
i live by a synagogue i guess it is
it's a jewish
center
for orthodox jewish people the reason
i'm not sure if it's a synagogue is i
always thought a synagogue looked
more synagogue like more like a church
yeah but it looks sort of like a like
almost like a rec center but i guess
that could be a synagogue too because
we're in the city so who knows i don't
know but the synagogue is a fun word it
is this a good word yeah both parts of
it and gog and you put them together
synagogue it's so funny it's a good word
so anyway might be one of my favorite
words
up there
i walk by this place all the time
because it's in my neighborhood and they
always think that i'm jewish
they're always asking me to come in and
you know that's it different it's always
a different guy saying my brother like
how are you would you would you like and
then i go i'm not jewish then they go oh
and then they turn they have no
need for you but i walked by the other
day it was a weekend afternoon they were
having some sort of like sort of like
cookout kind of thing
the [ __ ] yeah the god yeah
i hope they're calling it the gog on the
inside if you're not calling the gog you
guys are missing out you're jewish and
you belong to a gog
you're like come down to the [ __ ]
today i'm sorry i'm sorry i was at the
gog late last night
burgers and dogs i assume beef dogs i
assume
um but anyway i was walking by
and they saw the god bless shirt and
they started going shalom my brother god
bless shalom shalom
so now that not only did they think
you're jewish but now they think you're
actually religious yeah and now they
again it was like this is and i just i
forgot i was wearing the shirt so i just
turned around they go uh god bless and i
realized i was wearing the shirt
and i started laughing
and i don't think they saw me laughing i
hope they didn't because i was like i
didn't i wasn't laughing at them i was
just laughing like that's really funny
what just happened that's great but uh
but anyway yeah we made these god bless
ones just for the beacon show and uh la
which past couple days that we made
lakers colors yeah for them so yeah get
your merch right now on
salvocanocommunity.com i would love to
watch what you just described
you know should you have a reality show
something
i want somebody to latch on to one thing
i do
i'm tired of doing it we got we got a
whole army of taste buds this is our
thing i want one thing that i do for
people to go that's great and we're
behind it you're on one of the best
shows all the time i have security it's
not my show
okay it's not my i don't mean this show
i mean
i know what you mean i am on a lot of
other people's things
i just want my own thing just something
so i can know that i don't
die
salsa windfall
salsa windfall not my thing it's me and
paul
is it really
me and paul all right what about uh i
think you need to learn to share things
maybe share a thing i i i love you
uh what about your what about your
special
my special wow that did uh
your special was excellent i actually
heard it on sirius not too long ago when
i was driving i was on a long car ride
so we listened to it and it holds up and
it's very funny thank you i appreciate
it that
those compliments will
you know they don't pay for the milk
but uh
you know it's nice to hear but uh
there's no milk and joe's fridge
um but you're about to film another
special and maybe they'll latch on to
that
i was supposed to but the
you don't have to do it at a festival
why don't you just do it no i but where
i was shooting it at a festival and then
the festival got postponed so oh my god
so i can't god doesn't want you to have
milk
the love of god
um no i i actually want to develop the
cartoon idea with you of me as a boy but
except with my
the way i am now
let's do it
it was your idea i don't know but i mean
like
because i said about the ditch and you
said i want to do a show about you as a
child
because i would be like eating uh
reuben's
cocktails
and drinking coffee
hanging out in the ditch i love it it
sounds like salad fingers
[Laughter]
what a
oh that's it's a whole wormhole on
youtube oh really
creepy-ass cartoon from when i was a kid
oh i've seen that image before
yeah i know it but i don't know it know
it but i but i got i still got what you
meant people live by this this animation
that's great
this is shallow fingers
it's just so weird
oh this is from stoners i don't know who
this is for it's terrifying
i think they might have made like a
hundred episodes i don't know youtube
cartoons is a whole genre can i give a
shout out to is it kill tuna
kill tuna kill tuna
the guys who uh animated our
can you pull that up did we ever play
that on the pod itself oh did i tell you
i got robbed what
this is not the first podcast we filmed
today and i saw him the other day and i
just talked to him every day and he just
pulls that out of his ass like it's
nothing did i tell you i got robbed
what's these guys names right here these
guys are the best uh cartoon radio
cartoona radio they've animated a couple
of taste buds things and a couple of
things they are awesome they're amazing
they do such an amazing job they mine
for the comedy they know the moments
they create moments on their own uh the
animation is fun i i am when i am so
thrilled when they do something of ours
i appreciate it so much i actually uh
wanted to reach out to him just to do a
project so if you guys by the way who do
they have uh
do they have a youtube
it's cartoon cartoon radio i don't know
this is c-a-r our clip as in cartoon and
then a cartoon follow them wherever yeah
please
so funny they deal with a lot of
podcasts they're all great just really
talented group over there i don't know
them personally i don't know how many
there are
but uh we appreciate you guys and it's
so they're so good amazing the one they
did where you're the dog
oh that's what we were talking about
or whatever or something like that so i
was it was so endearing but this one the
fans went nuts for this one the kfc
versus taco bell one yeah yeah
it's so much so that i
i developed shows and i talked to
the company we're like we should maybe
do like this little one-off with them
maybe where we
hire them for some animation so i feel
like a cartoon of you and me might have
some legs too yeah oh yeah there was a
weird
there was something weird about this
where i was like
it i mean maybe it's for all of them and
maybe just because i'm seeing us i i
feel it's like when you see your own
kids you feel like more special yeah but
the way they did it the way they did it
and there was something about it where
they took the right sound i know i know
it was it was amazing that's what i'm
saying like what if there's an idea
where like we are characters
in this thing but maybe like we also do
the podcast
in the in the in the uh cartoon your
vase did a cartoon version of his
podcast already okay yeah that was what
it was
it was just them in the studio i don't i
mean no i'm saying like like build the
world out around us
but like the podcast is not it's not the
podcast it's not an hour-long podcast
like we are friends that in the cartoon
have a podcast and sometimes they'll
we'll put clips from the podcast in the
cartoon when we do the podcast but other
than that but there's a story around it
like marin like how marriage show was
like i didn't see marin but yeah i think
yeah but then build out the universe
around us like maybe we work at taco
bell kfc i love it this is something
happening behind the counter because
this isn't playing like the pod
this is playing like a conversation no i
agree if you combine wayne's world and
clerks i think that's yeah that would be
the sweet spot yeah something like that
i think we're onto something here i mean
look let's we should develop something
we should just proof of concepts right
here for jesus christ
let's talk about it yeah and
i like these guys too i would i would
talk to them about i like the aesthetic
man yeah cartoon radio send us your info
because all we have is right now is just
you send us clips send us like your
actual info dm it to us for sure yeah
we'll dig it out yeah um this podcast is
sponsored by
better help you knew we were going to
say it life can be overwhelming many
people are burned out without even
knowing it folks we've been through it
right here
right here for years and i knew he was
burned out he didn't know
uh and i might be burned out and he
knows and i don't know are you suffering
from lack of motivation yes feeling
helpless or trapped yes detachment yes
fatigue yes and more yeah yeah yeah uh
i'm ready for a change i don't know if
i'm coming or going i swear to you right
now i walk around my house
holding back tears and honestly people
we're being fun we're being funny but
this is not
well no i mean but but i was gonna say a
lot of truth is said in jest yes uh sal
and i actually are guys that do struggle
with these issues and better help is a
service we really do believe in we
realize these things can get very heavy
and very serious and we want you to get
the help you need with the uh uh the
ease that you deserve to get it
prioritize yourself
try it get some online therapy talking
with someone to help you figure out
what's causing the stress in your life
it's just not all work related there's a
lot of things that cause stress better
help is customized online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to that's the part i
found most helpful about better help was
the fact that not only were you able to
get the service in in any form you
wanted it but it could even go as far as
saying it can be cameras off sometimes
if you're not feeling great
the idea even looking at another person
while talking about your problems is too
much and you go i don't want to go i'm
going to cancel
the fact that they're they get that
that's huge therapy has never been
easier than this right it's huge it's
much more affordable than in person
therapy therapy it's true yeah it's more
affordable in person you can match with
therapists under 48 hours taste buds
listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
tastebuds that's betterhelphelp.com
tastebuds
guys i want to talk to you about peloton
because i ordered one in september and
it has really changed the way that i
make my excuses
no i'm that serious because i have a gym
where i live and i used to be like i
used to be like i don't want to drive to
the gym yeah then it was like i don't
want to go downstairs to the gym yeah
but now i have the pelt down it's like
basically a gym in my home and it it
does feel like a gym because it's
it's lively you you you you you work
with real people in real time with
trainers and they play music and you
could
there's so many functions that that
comes with the peloton packaging you
could do yoga there's there's all of
these workout routines and you just feel
like there's someone there to motivate
you which is one of my favorite things
about it they offer a great service and
a great product and i i have the i say
this but it's true i i have the app on
my ipad to use on my bike
uh and which is which is great i like
that peloton is letting you see and
experience what they do
even if you don't have one of their
bikes but we're here to tell you you
should probably buy one of their bikes
their bikes are great they have a team
of world-class instructors and they you
can use it 24 7. the instructors are
trained they're fitness pros they
motivate you with every workout it's
whether it's a regular gym workout or to
someone new
to working out or someone who's getting
back into working out whatever your
fitness level peloton instructors don't
just teach they motivate they've changed
thousands
of people's lives how through offering
thousands of live and live and on-demand
classes so you can always keep it fresh
you can cycle uh you can strength train
you can do yoga you can do running
classes uh you can experiment with new
types of movement judgment free in your
house babes that that's awesome because
i always feel like an idiot when i'm in
the gym trying anything i don't i don't
know i'm so intimidated that i because i
don't know what to do by everybody in
there but if it's not fun
i don't want to do it and they make it
fun i'm more you're more likely to stick
to a workout routine that you enjoy so
that's why they make the classes fun it
feels like you're hanging out with
friends like i said being able to pick
music specify what kind of music you
want to hear and all that sort of stuff
whether it's edm or soul
or wrap or whatever it doesn't matter
yeah you got it you know that's pretty
cool uh maybe you're looking for a
10-minute upper body stretch between
your calls or a 40-minute run right
before bed well that's something i do
peloton workers uh works with your
schedule whether you have five minutes
or now so that's the ease as well the
convenience is there you'll never have
an awkward encounter in a locker room
again you know some old guy with his
balls out whatever what have you right
now is the perfect time to try out
peloton the peloton bike plus is now 500
less
and then usual and that's the best price
they've offered yet it's including free
delivery and setup that's pretty great
uh and there are more game changing
prices available on the original peloton
bike and peloton tread visit one
peloton.com to learn more
oh so i got robbed not like at gunpoint
or anything but i i bought i mean this
is oh wait wait wait wait wait wait not
at gunpoint or anything yeah all right
move on um today's episode is bread and
butter versus charcuterie board
okay bread and butter uh i'm taking
bread and butter joe's taking cootery
boards what you're really committing to
this what do you mean the rob
well it wasn't my gunpoint yeah
all right go ahead
you trying to get into my guts right now
maybe should you get under my skin maybe
some guy scammed me online told me he
was selling me 15 bucks nintendo games
for 200. hold on a second dude hold on a
second dude
did you just make this story into
instead you you ordered something online
and it wasn't as advertised it was
craigslist but you just said you got
robbed yeah you got robbed for 215 oh
but joe everyone here thought you got
robbed in the real world that's why i
said it wasn't my gun point or anything
gunpoint or anything doesn't mean
anything i still kind of got jumped
mugged knife point stolen pickpocketed i
got jumped in here
oh my god
you click-baited us in real life
i did what he did to me to you because
that's how this vicious world was i i
got ripped off too recently online i
mean what do you want i mean i i it hurt
you said
i tell you guys i got fox mario 2 coming
to my house and i i didn't get it you
looked at us and said did i tell you
guys i got robbed our jaws dropped to
the floor like like the mounts from
castle grayskull
like a goddamn drawbridge and you knew
you knew we we felt that way because we
thought you got robbed in real life and
you still didn't say it until just now
you know what it is you know what it is
what is it it's time to get salty it's
time to get salty it's time to get salty
i don't like that you didn't like my
story and i'll tell you this right now
we're not in your house this couch is 10
times better
couch better your couch sucks that we
i
than
your
sit on everything oh [ __ ] you like this
couch buddy you fall asleep through half
the podcast i can't lift you up the
whole time you sit on as a couch to
podcast that abomination but you make
yourself fall asleep last episode
abomination you make us sit on every
week is a disgrace it is a disgrace you
want to talk
okay it's something you saw the exciting
insomnia
you dare call my couch an abomination
cut to the tape of his [ __ ] couch
it is the worst couch i have ever seen
in my entire life my couch upstairs
makes your couch look like it's just a
[ __ ] pile of dog [ __ ] you have a red
leather couch that is trying to be
modern it's so uncomfortable
it's not practical at all it's ten times
worse than my couch you it looks like
it's from a porn set
it looks like it's literally from a
point
it's like a guy trying to be hip getting
red leather but it just doesn't go you
need a you need an archie bunker that's
what you need an archie bunker type of
of of of recliner i got news for you you
needed to ask a red leather guy who are
you trying to fool you breathe
i got news for you
i get news for you i hate my couch
we all do that cut deep oh is there talk
about it
i mean joe your couch you have the
stones to talk about my couch your couch
it's not even real leather
it's fake red leather
it's uncomfortable convertible couch it
turns into a bed convertible yeah
convertible my ass it converts from a
piece of [ __ ] into a couch
oh wow all right let's go let's bring it
on here we go
it's time to b a t t l e buds bread and
butter versus charcuterie board salads
team bread and butter i am team
charcuterie board i can't believe you're
gonna try to put dough and butter up
against a board that contains multiple
cheeses cured meats and olives you are
out of your mind
you're out of your bread and butter
might be
outside of maybe pizza and chocolate the
best food in the invention of man
is the staple ingredient to anything
anyone eats that says it's delicious
go watch go watch uh what's his name
anthony bourdain read his book he says
the reason anything tastes like anything
in every restaurant you've ever is
purely butter butter is the cornerstone
from which all tastes come in food bread
bread fresh baked bread there is nothing
better than it warm
fresh every single restaurant begins
with bread i'm a big believer in this
you start your days with bread and
butter tote on toast i'm a huge believer
in fresh uh baked bread yeah it's a
staple of your sandwiches itself yes but
your sandwiches are good and what makes
them really really good is also fresh
it's the safe it's the staple it's what
you do with that bread and i think look
you want to talk my sandwiches the stuff
on my board going into the bread is ten
times better than the butter going on to
the bread it's what you do with that
bread you hand me a fresh break roll i'm
gonna go yes it's a very nice tasty
thing but i want something to do with
this now i said this before for a very
few foods in my lifetime but you can
make a michelin michelin-starred chef
prepare me a meal and then you could put
just a beautiful fresh baked basket of
bread in front of me with some butter if
let me tell you something right now if
if there wasn't health implications to
just literally just
throating bread and butter all the time
i would have bread and butter all the
time it is it is comforting
it is tasty it is crunchy it is smooth
and silvery
bread and butter falling out of your
obvious very strict health risks
let me tell you something
i'm doing any favors i know i know a
child county board is okay
you know what it is it's too rich it's
too rich it's too much i don't want to
eat i don't want to eat nine different
slices of processed meat
i don't want time i come to your house
for a function what is out of the table
before and after
a charcuterie board yes a charcuterie
board never have you put out bread and
butter well because it wants because
that's not apropos if i'm on company i'm
not going to put out baskets of bread
and butter right i'm talking about
theoretically i would love to have it
that's the best thing ever it is the
best thing ever in my opinion it is but
i don't know if people come over for a
social gathering if i'm just gonna put
out a basket of bread it's not the best
thing ever no it's just not appropriate
for that exact function in fact when you
have served a bread-based dish here in
the department of bread and butter it
has always been garlic bread even when
we've
even when we've had pasta dinners
together you have not put basic bread
because i'm going the extra mile with
the garlic bread but you're talking
about bread too joe you said my bread
you talk about everything bread
encompasses everything semolina bread
french bread english muffins rye bread
every single bread you can think of
is included in bread
butter on any of those things yeah but
we're not talking we're not fresh
we're not talking about the use of bread
we're not talking about the variety of
bread we're not talking about the the
corners the bread being a cornerstone
we're talking about the dish
specifically of butter on bread that's
what we're talking about i don't think
in other words a basket comes out you
butter a roll have you ever in your life
in your life and tell me the truth
because i think i know the answer pimp
you could weigh in as well
have either of you ever in your life
ever in your
lives
heard someone say they didn't like bread
and butter ever in your life
uh i can speak to that have i heard
somebody say they don't like it no have
i seen people
repeatedly push it aside at the top of a
meal in a restaurant because they don't
want to fill it up they're on a diet
they don't want to fill up they're on a
diet i've seen people like i've seen
people like better the water's too hard
i don't eat processed foods i don't eat
cured meats i don't need processed meats
i don't want i don't want cheese
charcoal i have never seen a strawberry
board at a table it's a beautiful
charcoal it looks beautiful people serve
it at weddings i didn't have never seen
a shark foodery hit a table that people
did not have i have never seen it i'm
talking about i've never seen one go
down i don't wanna i would rather have
bread and butter in front of me than a
board of charcuterie for me
it's only so much salami super sod
mortadelle and all that other stuff that
you could just so much bread and butter
you can eat there's almost not though i
would eat it i would eat it until i get
sick i would eat bread and butter until
i get sick i swear to you i would eat
social media
and cheese until i got sick it's too
much it's it's stewart and then you have
the shake i'll take you both both highly
very much high high sodium and processed
in both the meats and the cheeses look
your butterscotch you take a little you
take a little um your butter science
soda you realize that i know but i'm
it's it doesn't it's not like the meat
man
you take you take a slice of meat a
slice of butter or something right tasty
you take a little cheese you put it in
there you put a cracker with it eat it
it's nice but
two three of those i gotta tap out i'm
gonna chicken
butter every day could you eat
charcuterie every day yes you could eat
chocolate i do i eat at lunch almost
every day i eat a version of charcuterie
because i try not to eat bread a lot so
i'm eating i i
lives and and i mean you're leaving out
you're you're talking about just the
beets of cheeses
and meat and cheese you're going to make
me right now you go into my cabinet you
should see the pepper game i have going
on in my apartment right now you should
see the pepper hold on hold on you're
going to an empty pasta i'm talking
charcoal charcuterie can contain peppers
because it's instagramable and
photographical why and why it's why it's
spiking in popularity because people
like to arrange the patterns and show
them different can you tell me though
can you get me the distinct definition
of charcuterie a charcuterie board you
go to italy i think i think i thought it
was just really meats maybe meats and
cheeses you can add you can add it's
finger foods on a board
charcuterie is a specific term with
origins reaching as far back as the 15th
century france literally translated it
means the products of a fancy pork
butcher modern charcuterie does often
include pork but the definition has wine
to reflect the dish served throughout
many cultures but okay so but what is
what is
okay
what is the difference between a cheese
board and a charcuterie board the main
difference between charcuterie and
cheese board is their ingredients
charcuterie basically refers to various
meat products you got pictures on the
sheets these boards refer to cheeses you
got pictures on the side panel where
you're seeing olives you're seeing
crackers all of these are that's cheese
and charcuterie board and it's yes
charcuterie is meat joe chocolate is
meat
that's a charcuterie board right there
there's tomatoes on it there's bread
there's all kinds of stuff on a
charcuterie board it is not just meat
and cheese it can be that passes as one
but i have rarely seen a charcuterie
board worth its salt that is just meat
and cheese now back to your question
could i eat it every day yes i
absolutely could and i will say this
okay uh
uh you go to italy you go to italy i'll
tell you what you're getting at every
meal
okay you eat in rome some of the finest
restaurants in the world
that a charcuterie board is hitting that
table at the top of every meal before
bread and butter
bread butter are you insane have you
been to rome yeah
a charcuterie board is not first of all
charcuterie boards are not free
bread is complimentary oh i'm not saying
it was free you're saying it's hitting
the table before bread i'm saying in
italy in italy fresh baked bread is
coming out with every meal i'm saying
every meal i ate in italy in a
restaurant it was it was more or less
suggested
by the uh uh like with like with the
wine like would you like a charcuterie
board to start things off like let's get
it going you know you brought up italy
you're out of line italy is bread coming
out
italy italy's bread with olive oil
that's what comes out first if you're
italian that's it bread and butter
but it's bread you said chocolate
cookies coming out before bread and
butter they bring out butter butter
they bring out butter
yes they do they bring up water and
olive oil
and when in rome
uh you know honestly if i woke up every
day right and i and i came and i sat out
in my living room or whatever and
someone dropped a charcuterie board in
front of me every day just the thought
of that i don't want it for breakfast
sounds i could eat bread and butter for
breakfast lunch dinner or snack
breakfast lunch dinner or snack is what
i said
i could eat bread and butter at any
point in the day accompanying any meal i
just charcuterie i you i cringe at the
thought of
if you told me you're gonna do a 30-day
truck kudery board challenge where i had
to eat charcuterie board every day for
30 days i inside right now i'm dry
heaving a little bit it's too
much it's rich
it's over the top i don't want eat i
don't want processed meat and cheese
every day
okay so what are you eating for lunch
every day
a host of things go ahead give it to me
you're home you're not on set somebody's
not making it for you sure what are you
eating for lunch every day
you're eating a sandwich
no sandwich is a big lunch food sure
okay how many times in the week eating a
sandwich as you say a charcuterie board
is too much you're taking the elements
of a charcuterie board and then you're
putting it on bread not really because
ham and cheese is not really made from
i'm not going to have like mortadella
every day you could have ham on a
charcuterie board you could have turkey
on a charcuterie board i mean you i'm
eating a salad i'm eating a piece of
grilled chicken i'm eating uh you know
pizza i'm eating pizza and the
charcuterie is too heavy for you no but
i'm just saying this i'm not just eating
the the ingredients of a charcuterie
board every day i i could i could get
down with a charcuterie almost every day
of the week the only thing that makes me
say no to that i mean a wrap is there's
not one food i don't want to eat every
single day i i want to break it up but
i'm saying i would get sick if
challenged to eat chocolate every day
whereas if i had a piece of toast with
butter i'm going to take you to the most
we're not even talking about toast but
dude you know what i mean i'm just
talking about
bread and butter as far as i'm concerned
toast doesn't count in your argument as
far as i'm
concerned what no why would it
why would it because that's not what it
is
bread and butter here's what i'm going
to start doing i swear to god it's a new
segment right before we start i'm going
to take my blood pressure i swear to god
i have the machine it's right there i
put it on my arm i take my blood sugar
i'm going to take my blood pressure from
now on before we begin before it's going
to open up he's going to say hey hey
taste buddies it's time for ts t buds
i'm going to take the blood pressure it
takes 30 seconds and then i'm going to
take it as soon as we finish the episode
and i want you to see what he does to me
why would i go into a grave earlier
because of him why would toast count
okay you're heating up bread i could
take the cheese of the meat from the
charcuterie board and throw it in a pan
and heat it up i mean what are we
talking about here bread and butter is
not i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry if i bake bread and i take it
out of the oven and that ain't toasted
bread
piping that ain't toasted bread we bake
bread every day at the shop that is not
toasted bread it is if you eat it when
it comes out of the oven no it is not it
is not toasted bread toast and bread are
two different things those are two
different toasters bread
it's bread
oh boy you know you need to make toast
bread
it's made from bread
but it's a preparation of bread so if
you tell me you tell me that you want to
heat up
part of your chocolate report that's not
charcuterie anymore no what is it no
chocolate or is that hot it's not served
hot it's not what it is that's not
served but bread is served hot
bread and butter you know what it means
don't you be slick with me it's taking a
piece of wonder bread out of the thing
it's not sugaring oh look that's what he
introduced me to he's
pulling out a slice pulling out the
cheapest slice of white bread you can
find the best you can't even spread
butter on by the way because it'll tear
the bread off i said butter and rolls at
the restaurant but toast is a different
ball game when a bread and a bread
basket comes out at the top of a meal at
a restaurant and it's hot what's going
on though not toasted it's just fresh
those are two different things those are
two different things when you open that
bread up the interior of that toast okay
hot bread okay
it's different things is toast not hot
different thing nope toast is toasted
different thing okay different thing
this this is a guy who called the crepe
a pancake and he's telling me that if i
if i put it by definition if i put a
little bit
if i put a little heat on toast it's no
longer bread a little heat on bread it's
nice
go back to whatever that just said about
the misconception of hot bread
one common bread out of the oven is
actually not ready to be eaten
what conversation are you joining no
it's not toast because toast is meant to
be eaten oh great joe great you should
have adopted right right fresh br is
fresh baked bread toast
backed he writes
who do you think's writing an article on
this
our bread and toast sanding toast is
bread that has been browned
brown
toast is bread it's the most
fresh bread
you can't you can't answer my question
in fewer than three words the first
three words of toast is bread you said
it out of your mouth i'm gonna take you
to the most basic
his breath i'm gonna take you you can't
even say it i'm gonna take you to the
most basic charcuterie and i could [ __ ]
with it every day of the week all right
sharp white cheddar cheese or vermont
extra sharp pepperoni sharp baby it's
too rich i love it you can eat some
cheese every day finish extra a
pepperoni stick and a box of triscuit
crackers you give me briskets
you are 95 years old
triscuits i could eat it every day oh my
god
you're eating grape nuts
are you eating grape nuts no
you sure positive triscuits i'm positive
triscuits are the shredded wheat of the
cracker world you put a sharp cheese and
pepperoni on them they're bad oh i hate
a triscuit i don't really hate it solo i
don't
know
something you don't know you're such a
dumb child i'm a dumb child you're an
old old crotchety man okay well an old
country man that has food experience
knows how to eat food triscuit is your
food experience it's nabisco it's an
island yeah you got food experience i
like bread
[Laughter]
where are we at pimp
uh we're at about 40 minutes here all
right take us to the phones
we didn't go to the phones last episode
we did it
it was like a jungle gym that was like
too much to cover all right ready let's
see what the people have to say lex is
saying
by the way before we get into this do us
a favor we forget to say this
if you don't subscribe to no pressure on
youtube please subscribe if you don't
follow us on itunes or on spotify just
hit that button it means a lot and like
those videos yeah like our videos if you
leave a like or rating or stars whatever
anything a comment it helps us so so
much we never asked for we're going to
start just reminding you guys because we
think that you guys will do it for us
and if you like the pod it helps the
podcast ratings on itunes
rate it on itunes the second the second
uh tweet down infuriates me and how
little some people know about anything
bread and butter is a classic when you
go to a high-end restaurant they're not
giving you a random board a board of
random meats yes they are
yes they are if you want actually
something that if you order it she's
saying though that they that that you
would never find that by the way miss
they're not giving you a random board of
meats no the board's not random the
meats are random it's a board of ranch
she's saying everything can you scroll
up a little bit she's saying everything
i said bread and butter is a classic
when you go to a high-end restaurant
they're not giving you a random board of
meats they're giving you fresh delicious
bread and high-end butter cause it's all
you need never mind the types of bread
and butter you can mix and match she's
saying that a high-end restaurant
doesn't carry a charcuterie which is so
wrong it's insane let's keep going let's
go right in a row nothing beats when
you're starving and you sit down at a
restaurant the first thing you eat is
bread butter yeah you ruined your meal
but if they brought the charcuterie
instead of bread wouldn't you be blown
away charcuterie board say i'm fancy
wait scroll
stop scroll back up scroll back up for a
second show the reply to that but if
they brought the charcuterie board
instead i want to see what she says
never in my life
and i'll go as far as people said it's
never happened in the history well of
course it's never happened it's you have
to pay for it that's the other thing by
the way you get bread for free because
it's it's it's
it's [ __ ] jesus multiplied loaves baby
jesus you turned to
the bible jesus is sitting multiplying
boys
multiplying charcuterie boards he's
multiplying bread not a single thing on
planet earth beats bread and butter oh
yeah no no not medicine not sunshine
chuckering gotten out
yeah yeah nothing on earth isabella
beats bread and butter
uh i am from the land of bread and cold
cuts this is tough going for charcuterie
thank you sabrina charcuterie board all
day every day because i'm not a fan of
brad or butter
leo's a typo uh i'll try the bread of
joey roses when we visit the summer
that's a good fan right there bread and
butter is a gift straight from the gods
no from god's ass
oh but no that's a good thing
throw some cinnamon and sugar on toast
that's how we're talking about greg
charcuterie boards are for girls that
say i'm full after one slice of
flatbread i don't understand what that
means
jesus
wait keep going charcuterie bored all
the way bread and butter is the thing
you eat at a restaurant while you're
waiting for something better thank you i
know joe picked charcuterie board
wouldn't be the first time he has had a
right
underscore frosty underscore and that's
mike uh keep your fancy meat tray and
give me a bad get with a stick of butter
any day boom boom
bread and butter is what my poor mother
taught me was a meal growing up
oh my god
that is very i haven't eaten bread in
five years
wait just go back up a little more a
little more i haven't eaten bread in
five years but i've dreamt of it while
eating tiny chocolate report sandwiches
with cheese slices as bread
bread okay bread and butter has been
bringing families and enemies together
since the beginning of time that's
another thing babe sit down deals are
made hits are ordered on people hold on
religions hold on you break bread come
in my house break bread stop breaking it
you can't use the phrase bread and
butter as a literal meaning nobody is
nobody is getting together over bread
and butter it's a phrase it's a cliche
it's a phrase because you break bread at
the top of every meal sharing a meal
with something special have you ever
done that when have you broken bread
with people at the top of a meal it
comes sliced in a basket at best
serving and sharing bread is what
breaking bread means nobody's like you
know what i want to meet you and your
family i want to meet you and your
family come to my house share some super
sad with me oh yeah pimp guess what i've
been to his house several times you know
what we've shared super soft never once
was bread and butter because that's not
what you do at a gathering you don't put
out bread at a gathering you just said
you do at a meal joe
when you've come off for dinner bread
and butter is on that team you're all
over the map you're over the map deli
meat is gross in every way everyone
might not say it but they know it bread
and butter is a classic and it never
gets old and then jack white mike
replies with deli meat what kind of
charcuterie has you had and i i agree
with him i was today years old realizing
that a charcuterie board was what i was
eating when i went to eat certain
gatherings okay
i usually go my gut on these but this
one had me pause it's a tough one
charcuterie board gives me anxiety way
too many options that's interesting
half the people picking charcuterie
board can't pronounce truck hootery
board the right answer is bread and
butter and it always will be stop it
uh you're going to need to explain what
a charcuterie board is well you're
sitting at the device that can't explain
that to you
jesus christ there's a reason bread and
butter is used as a common phrase no one
says that's the charcuterie board of
something
bread and butter oh yeah that's true too
so you have the language market cornered
i can't [ __ ] with you yeah this is the
bread and butter of all babe yeah i mean
look at that look at the the gravitas
that the phrase bread and butter holds
all right let's go let's give the wind
to the meats of the mouth
just right where you are charcuterie
more like shark kill me
uh let's give the wind to the meats in
the mouth guy yeah
uh follow him oh my leg is cramping up
follow him at follow him at all my leg
is cramping up at so underscore frosty
underscore
all right ready go to
see you win this thing
here we go 10 11 11 10 100 votes
pimp's going bread and butt
he doesn't know where he's going i'm
nervous oh
[Music]
give me a break with this
[Music]
bread and butter takes it
56.9
to 43.1 percent that was a battle
i thought bread and butter was going to
win big it didn't win big big
you want to end it or do you want to
just
yeah come on it's the end my leg is
crazy i can't sit down just end it
tickets on sale right now
for vegas phoenix boulder colorado
seattle portland vancouver
i'm not going to plug again at the end
go see one go to joey rosa at 174
remington i still love you babe i love
you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds